[Music]
all right and we are live I love
podcasts Lords of gaming dotnet who are
these fine gentlemen in the realm today
hi my name is Eric and from Team Ontario
I'm the lead developer of this game and
the name of this team team I'm Harry oh
all right here we go and yourself sir
I'm Talbert winner I am a composer sound
designer oh yeah
well I don't make the music for this
project but I made the sound design with
this project nice awesome and this is
something that the Lords have caught our
eye on fictions will tell us a little
bit about fictions fear I saw well
fictions fear is a beat-em-up platformer
you know it's very traditional Mega Man
or you know run-and-gun kind of thing
but obviously that's not where it really
shines I think we're really shine just
like it's a it's it's inspired by a lot
of the early nineties style video games
they talked about language now keep
going
yeah it's like there's a lot of
beat-em-up elements in there like
Streets of Rage is a very huge
inspiration right you know Street
Fighter I'm a huge fighting game fan so
it's always been a big part of my
childhood and of course Megaman you know
we can't really forget it forget the
King og exactly exactly but yeah I don't
like the entire premise of the game is
that you're basically crafting your own
custom combos so rather than like
traditional beat em ups and you know
platformers
you'll actually be able to just be fancy
with it be fancy with the combos yeah so
explain that because you said we're not
going to traditional route like how do
you either create and get into that
expansiveness with the combos oh yeah so
basically like in traditional beat em up
games you know you're very limited with
what you can do right like so you know
if you just BAM the punch plane you know
just do a full combo string so win this
game and actually punishes you for it
for not being able to create your own
combos but overall don't like you know
it's a learning process so you know what
are you buddies filming right now in the
top left corner of the screen you'll see
like three abilities yes I see two three
right so in order to toggle them you'll
have a button that basically does a full
auto combo by itself now obviously
that's not the best way to go because
you're gonna be using a lot of energy
and burning a lot of your resources okay
so the idea is that you want to mix and
match between like you know your Buster
shot your basic attack like your basic
punches and your melee punches and what
it will do is that know whenever you do
your basic punches it toggles to the
next ability and that's how you
basically you're gonna be able to create
your own unique combos you know that way
you're not just pressing me like an auto
combo all the time - now tell us about
level design in stages as far as
pictures feel like how what are we
looking at as far as level design well I
mean honestly with the level design it's
going to be very similar to the
traditional Megaman
design obviously like we're trying to
fit in the beat-em-up platformer aspect
on there as well there's a lot of other
cool unique features on the - inspired
by like Wild guns I don't know yeah yeah
absolutely absolutely so like you know
there's a gallery shooter section so we
want to try that I guess like mix and
match all those elements together it's
been very hard but like you know I think
that the demo itself right now
really honestly shown like how we're
gonna be creating the rest of the stage
the rest are levels sounds good man is
first of all the art style looks
absolutely fantastic definitely like a
throwback to those retro style games
that I grew up in I love and the other
thing I want to know is let's get to the
narrative like who is this character
what is this world about what are we
doing here well it's very complicated
story I guess you could say bow I'll
give you like a short run the cliff
notes so the thing is that our carrot
our main character his name is ratio so
yeah what we call the power of affinity
so it's kind of like a little pun on it
okay so if it's eysan with this gameplay
about what I was mentioning for what
with the energy and like you know
constantly beating your enemies I always
building back their resources so
basically this world that we set up is
that the and this is like in the near
near far future near far ruko basically
there's a plague called a fancy Rio
that's basically spread about the entire
earth you know what a plague right so
it's transforming humans it's like
morbid upon abominations called
phantasms okay right they're like aliens
and demonic like creatures so the thing
is that the robots that you see in the
game right now they're sort of like a
countermeasure to be able to fight
against them
don't see them in the game right now but
you know later on when we release a
little bit more info on them you know
you gotta see like they're very
terrifying alien okay kind of creatures
uh so the thing is is that these robots
think that our main character ratio is
an alien creature and so hence why he
has to fight kind of both factions at
the same time so like it's sort of like
the whole world is against them gotcha
so is this really going against the
world right now I guess like you know we
want to put in some hardships in there
for our main character you know man this
thing looks really good now as far as
platforms what are we currently on right
now all right so right now we're doing a
Kickstarter we actually just got funded
yesterday awesome we like we got
kickstart is in a realm right now it's
currently on the PC but you know the
kick started as well where planets
really sound like switch yes did you say
defend oh so I think this would be a
perfect fit yeah everybody always ask
that y'all right now right I feel I'm
feeling switch vibes man got that a lot
from people thought things going to
happen not gonna lie even if we don't
reach it we're gonna try to we're gonna
try to actually port it out for this
which was very popular platform
everybody loves it
and everybody loves indie games on it
yeah absolutely man
so give the final pitch for new sell
people on fixings fear man
help to sell people on sell the Lord's
on picture fiction spear I mean listen
even though we already sold if you if
you're a fan of like 90s gaming a little
bit of a twist this is gonna be
completely for you one of your favorite
aspects of it honestly Szabo's i think
that it's just it hits my childhood man
like if I could say anything this is
where I grew up
I'm when I look at it I feel a Mediate
nostalgic moment and I think a lot of
players are gonna feel the same thing
I'm getting them Bob's y'all man the
fictions fear keep your eyes on it where
can the people go to support fictions
beer well you could definitely find us
on Facebook and Twitter you guys are
search helped our name to mine Harry oh
that's spell that name you know it's
hard come on you guys spell that name
you know I don't expect anybody to get
it but obviously team GE am I'm Harry
our spell key i n h PR j AR so you can
find those facebook and twitter you
follow if you follow us you'll see all
of our updates and all about hard work
that we've been
last few days and whatnot awesome man I
think I think you guys would definitely
like it for sure yeah we got our eyes on
the saw of his hook he's not moved
put it on saw he ever move his position
since we got these it is day one this
guy right here you already here first
man plate New York City fictions fear
the Lord's definitely have their eye on
this fantastic art style loving the
vibes classic 90s retro we got some beat
them up we got some mega man we got some
Streets of Rage it's looking good guys
man fantastic thanks for having us
thanks Robin thank you thank you thank
you
[Music]